si la parole devant dame nicole ameline
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur le ministre
le dialogue interlibyen a conduit le 9
octobre dernier à un accord politique
qui marque l'aboutissement du processus
engagé sous l'égide des nations unies et
soutenu par la communauté internationale
dont la france et qui marque également
une étape positive nous savons que ce
progrès est fragile il n'est pas moins
réelle et nous force à agir car la libye
est un élément déterminant de notre
sécurité
chacun mesure en effet la progression
croissante de dèche là l'absence de
contrôle des frontières et la montée de
l'insécurité ainsi que le chaos
économique qui menace non seulement la
libye bien sûr aujourd'hui mais
l'ensemble des pays riverains et
l'europe elle-même
chacun mesure également l'impact que
pourrait avoir le maintien d'une
situation comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui dans ce pays sur
les pays riverains qui risquerait eux
mêmes une déstabilisation aggraver la
réaction européenne s'impose elle
s'impose à plusieurs titres
nous devons en effet avoir une vision
immédiate et également à plus long terme
des mesures à prendre
en libye en termes de gouvernance de
soutien au processus institutionnel et
politique de redressement économique et
de sécurisation
car bien sûr y compris la question des
réfugiés s'analyser se règlent d'abord
et avant tout sur place sur le terrain
la france pourrait-elle envisager de
prendre le leadership en tout cas la
présidence du comité d'inde à pilotage
politique sur les solutions à prendre
dans cette partie du monde
quant à l'europe assez invisible jusque
alors sur ce dossier pourrait-elle
envisager de redéployer ses moyens en
terme de politique de voisinage et
d'intervenir afin qu'une solution
politique puisse avoir rapidement un
contenu et un soutien je vous remercie
merci la parole est un monsieur le
ministre des affaires étranges
madame la députée nicole ameline je me
retrouve tout à fait dans la façon dont
vous avez posé la question et exposer
les solutions la stabilisation la libye
pour toutes les raisons que vous avez
fort bien dit est une priorité
ces talismans savoir fois pour les
libyens et pour l'ensemble de la région
pour la lutte contre le terrorisme
alors monsieur bernard lévy au nez on a
fait des efforts qu'il faut saluer il
dit et nous souhaitons que ce soit le
cas que maintenant la solution qu'il a
proposée va permettre un accord
interlibyen il a proposé qu'un
gouvernement d'unité nationale soit
formé sous avec à sa tête monsieur
faille et sa rage et nous soutenons
clairement cette proposition même si
jusqu'à présent le congrès général
national à tripoli et la chambre des
représentants a tôt à tobrouk ne se sont
pas explicitement prononcer mais
évidemment c'est une priorité une fois
l'accord signé c'est dans ce cadre là
que je me situe
les partenaires régionaux et
internationaux devront le soutenir c'est
à dire notamment l'europe et c'est à
dire évidemment la france et nous serons
je vais être clair aux côtés du futur
gouvernement d'unité nationale pour le
soutenir face aux défis auxquels il sera
confronté qui sont à la fois nature
politique de nature sécuritaire est de
nature économique
je m'en suis entretenu avec mes
collègues européens et je les pousse
ainsi que vous l'avez dit à ce que nous
réorientons où nous aurions trop nos
efforts dans le sens que vous avez
indiquée parce qu'il y va de notre
responsabilité collective au service la
sécurité de la paix et la france bien
entendu sera présente en songeant à ce
qui s'est passé dans les années 2010
2011 et en évitant certaines erreurs qui
ont pu être commises à cette période
mais il est clair que l'intérêt est de
trouver la stabilité et l'unité en libye
s'il a parlé d'un monsieur michel piron